let's talk about how to get rid of your
facial hair if you are female
the medical term for this is
hirsutism it follows more male pattern
where there's hair on the face okay
there's hair sometimes on the back
and the chest as well
now the number one cause of this
condition
is
pcos polycystic ovarian
syndrome okay there are other causes too
like you could have a tumor on your
adrenal glands or a tumor
on your pituitary gland you could also
have a condition called cushing's
syndrome where your adrenals are pumping
out way too much cortisol okay and the
symptoms for pcos
are heavy cycles or no cycles acne
weight gain in the mid section deeper
voice
infertility they also say when you look
this up in wikipedia
insulin resistance
all because of high
androgens okay now normally women should
have some androgens but it shouldn't be
excessive there's usually lower amounts
of androgens and higher amounts of
estrogen now the reason you're probably
watching this is because you have facial
hair and you're trying to solve this
problem but it's incredibly confusing
and i'm going to tell you why it's
incredibly confusing
and
what to do about it now if you research
facial hair you're going to stumble on
this pcos thing and then you're probably
going to want to look at some
really credible
scientifically based
evidence
on this topic so you can do your
research so of course you'd go to
wikipedia which i'm being extremely
sarcastic because
this is like random.com who's really
censoring information who's allowing
certain information and
not allowing certain information
so it's a crap shoot on wikipedia
especially if you're looking at medical
information because wikipedia as far as
pcos will tell you that it's genetic
or it's environmental that's probably
true that it's causing something but not
necessarily high androgens those
plastics and chemicals are endocrine
disruptors but they're they're mainly
going to increase estrogen okay and if
you increase
estrogen you're going to lower
androgen so you might even make a little
bit better and change the ratios but
probably not
but they will go on to say there's no
cure okay but you can also in the
meantime take birth control pills so
again why would that work well you're
increasing the ratios of estrogen and
hopefully bringing down
androgens
also metformin why would that work well
it's going to help
reduce insulin by making insulin more
sensitive because it targets insulin
resistance but it has side effects
because it is a medication they also
recommend certain drugs that
make insulin more sensitive now as far
as the diet what they recommend
they recommend low gi foods so foods
that are low in the glycemic index which
makes total sense because obviously
there's insulin resistance involved
right but of course the foods that they
recommend
will confuse you
fruit so why would eating fruits help
you lower
insulin it doesn't it
raises insulin because they are sweet
okay they recommend vegetables and whole
grains
i hope someday someone will let me know
why eating whole grains
are good for
facial hair or pcos or lowering insulin
i'd like to know
because this turns into carbohydrates
very quickly and it's going to raise
insulin okay but of course everything
you're looking at now they always have
to recommend
whole grains okay now with pcos there
also is an association with
hyperinsulinemia that's high insulin in
your bloodstream okay so
let's go over to wikipedia and see what
they say about hyperinsulinemia okay
they say the cause comes from either
a neoplasm which is cancer pancreatic
cancer
trans fats
pcos which is very confusing so
basically they're saying pcos
causes
high insulin in the blood
i mean that makes
no sense and now you're going to be
really confused right
what's the relationship there how could
pcos high levels of androgens actually
cause
hyperinsulinemia
it can't it's illogical
and then they recommend carb
malabsorption whatever the heck that
means okay you're male absorbing your
carbohydrates
i have no clue what that means okay
but i'm glad they have a treatment
because the treatment is exercised okay
it's metformin
and again they add the whole grains as
your diet whole grains beans and
definitely soy okay so that's what you
should be eating if you have too much
insulin based on wikipedia so at this
point in your research you're going to
be utterly completely confused simply
because you are doing your evaluation
from a bad source from the wrong source
okay wikipedia is not the best source of
data you should be
evaluating this problem on i'm going to
put some good references down below so
you can see these but here's what's
missing
on the wikipedia pages
when you increase insulin when you have
excess insulin
you're going to get high androgens okay
high insulin causes
high levels of androgens which then
cause pcos which then give you
facial hair okay
that's the connection high insulin is at
the root
of pcos
and facial hair and so the solution is
obviously to lower insulin and if you do
that and you look at this
everything
makes sense because as soon as you lower
insulin you lower androgens and guess
what happens your cycle comes back in
balance your acne goes away you become
more fertile okay and you also get rid
of insulin resistance so you're going to
lose weight and also the fat cells will
stop producing this other thing it's an
enzyme that's called aromatase aromatase
is basically kind of this enzyme that
converts your testosterone to estrogen
so it raises your estrogen okay that's
probably what's behind this
no cycle infertility problem but
obviously this extra fat that's making
this extra estrogen
is not necessarily countering the high
levels of androgen because the diet
needs to change to fix that now how do
you lower insulin okay
very simply you lower carbohydrates and
you lower the frequency of meals like
get rid of the snacks
the best video on that i'm going to put
up is right here
check it out
you